si no solamente se realizó un
allanamiento 11 allanamientos como tú
has dicho con la detención de cinco
personas también se ha dado información
sobre lo que considera el ejecutivo en
nacional el ministro de interior y
justicia patricio carrillo ha dicho que
existe una relación de un decomiso de
droga realizado el pasado 12 de agosto
con este atentado el ejecutivo nacional
está tratando de esto como un atentado
terrorista y ha dicho que el decomiso de
250 kilos de droga y tiene amplia
relación con lo sucedido a la madrugada
el día domingo de igual forma ha
informado que el líder de una
organización delictiva sería el blanco
de este atentado que ha ocasionado el
fallecimiento de cinco personas estado
que reacciones se han producido dentro
del gobierno después de esta tercera
declaración del estado de emergencia en
guayaquil
bueno la principal reacción se ha dado
por parte del ejecutivo nacional en
principio anuncia un estado de estado de
cesión figurar a los próximos 30 días no
y justifica también este estado de
decisión porque debes tomar en cuenta
que los niveles de muertes violentes ha
encendido en el último año en el año
2017 fueron de 126 muertes violentas y
eso se ha triplicado a
861 muertes en lo que va de año de igual
forma también se han atendido ya 23
personas en 4 hospitales de los cuales
11 de ellas se han dado de alta para el
día de hoy también se espera información
por parte de reacciones por parte del
presidente de la república para hacer
seguimiento de lo que está pasando en el
barrio el cristo del consuelo de la
ciudad guayaquil bueno en algún momento
se se pensó que el presidente iba a ir
hasta el lugar de los hechos pero hasta
este momento no ha ocurrido
si efectivamente se esperaba que el
presidente de la republica asistiera a
esta zona de la explosión pero dado a su
agenda la secretaria de comunicación de
la presidencia de república ha dicho que
no pudo asistir a este evento por el
cual se espera también declaraciones de
distintos personeros de la secretaria de
seguridad del estado